there is now
fury over wonder woman uh the
upcoming movie and the fury from the
social justice left over the fact that
wonder woman
is promoting protein bars
the slogan is think thin because
we couldn't have a superhero being super
i mean first off this is a superhero no
one expects these superheroes to be
you know a representation of the average
person they're superheroes
sure they have super powers and so it's
it's a tale as old as time first off
that when you have people who are
in great shape or people who are
attractive they advertise products for
fitness and beauty
because people want to buy those
products and feminists complain all the
time about how they don't
who where's our hero they don't have
enough strong female characters
well here you have this woman who plays
wonder woman they want this
the strong we don't have enough strong
female characters for ourselves first
off the reason you don't is because
women tend to get their ass kicked in
real life ronda rousey get her ass
kicked by an average middleweight at a
local
smoker fight let's just be realistic
about that but when you go into the
realm of superpowers fine we'll give it
to you
now they have a strong ass-kicking
female this is actually an israeli woman
who served in the israeli defense forces
she's one of the most badass militaries
out there a strong
uh vocal i guess you'd say classical
feminist
who actually kicked people's asses and
they're upset because it's not
a fat blue-haired feminist whiny
amoeba who supports hamas it's never
enough
that's not very intimidating you're
right you're not for them
can we have can we have like could we
have like a fat palestinian superhero
feel like you feel like any schumer
likes to be really really refreshing
they want to encourage people to have
good health healthy self-esteem she's
with the mtv awards
trans self-esteem you should be happy we
want to encourage healthy self-esteem
that you're happier well okay let's talk
about health and self-esteem obesity
rate in the united states for women is
rising from 38 percent to 41 percent in
10 years
we know the health risks the sodium
associated with obesity we've talked
about this many times eighty percent uh
risk of type two diabetes
cancers it is unhealthy it's bad for
your joints people won't have sex with
you there are a multitude of reasons
as to why you don't want to be
overweight
they're taking a beautiful superhero who
has a great story to tell is a strong
woman
and it's not enough and this is why
there should be no compromise
with the anti-free speech totalitarian
left because when you put forward
someone like this and you go you know
what this is a woman great strong
israeli defender
no because why she sold a
protein bar okay that's enough it was
enough of a backlash
this is true this was at gizmodo it was
enough of a backlash they created this
campaign
everyone can be we are all wondering
i love first off i love ho ho ho keep
that up i love how
the biggest first off it's racist
because the tallest one is black
what do you think she's some amazonian
yeah and then tribal lady
wonder woman in the wheelchair
no the wheelchair can't be wondering
because one woman has super powers
this is true she has she doesn't get in
they have healing abilities
it doesn't work they totally miss the
point they'd be like wolverine it's like
i have mutant healing abilities also
zoom out i have ricketts
like all this all of a sudden superman
is like doc holiday has to move out west
because of his tuberculosis
these are super heroes we're all wonder
woman i thought this was
self-explanatory
they've just they've gone so far and by
the way i'm so happy they're doing this
because
there's there's going to be backlash oh
absolutely the genderless mtv awards
the rolling stone comedians pushing
please and now the one
we don't have wonder woman in a
wheelchair and protein bars it's just
please continue and we wanted to put it
to the test uh if can we all be
wondering i think we are all
wonder woman i absolutely believe that
so aaron the intern come on out here
aaron aaron the intern we aaron the
intern needs to come out here to put
this oh aaron the intern
there he is there he is come on come on
come on we can all be
one bring it in baby
oh that is that is uh testicle
retractingly scary
aaron the intern aaron the intern do you
um
do you feel wonderful thank you stephen
well i pretty much figured that's not
nice to see you
yes seriously though i mean this is
about empowerment since we're empowering
women i love you
i love empowered no you don't feel
empowered
do you feel wonderful do you feel as
though you're you're more like you're
representing the
unheard voice out there you guys go to
hell
it's about empowerment you know what i
think i think the reason that uh wonder
woman doesn't feel
wonderful enough yet is because what's
one without her without her invisible
jet
ooh when you take don't take a ride in
your invisible jet
come on you're in the internet you take
a ride on your invisible you said you
would
it's it's the wonderful thing is yours
take the ride in your invisible jab
maybe
maybe you need some music maybe some
music to cue him
there all right now hold on so you need
to open the door you get an invisible
jet
open the door to get the invisible jet
air in the intern
okay now you get in the jet there you go
there you go you got it this isn't this
is empowering come on
items fire well a second can you shift
the jet closer to my table because
you're kind of
it's empowering we want to empower it
get squat like you're really in a jet no
one sits like that in an invisible jet
don't have going half-assed this wonder
woman okay there you go
there you go ryan how fast are you going
whoa wonder woman
[ __ ] you guys air in the internet
he has no appreciation uh for the wonder
and splendor that is women
hey this video was taken as a clip from
the full show daily show at lottery with
credit.com club where it's available
exclusively 69
a year that's less than six dollars a
month less than two expensive cups of
coffee or you can feed an african child
but why would you want to
just buy coffee or join the mug club
daily show lottery squadron.com
mug club see you there don't feed
children